Hey, Matt. Whatcha doin'?
>> Oh, hey. Not much, just a little light reading, I suppose.
>> Did you start the Game of Thrones series?
>> Well, nothing quite that dense, but I'm reading my genome, actually.
>> Really, what does it say?
>> Some pretty cool stuff here. Actually, I've got
blue eyes, apparently. my blood type is O positive.
I seem to be able to digest lactose products
pretty well. I can't taste bitter flavors. A cup
of coffee late at night doesn't bother
me, because I metabolize caffeine pretty quickly,
and somewhere in here, oh, I actually had a, an increased risk for Alzheimer's.
>> It tells you all of that? I want to see it. Actually,
your genome has a lot more information than just what you see here.
Your genome can reveal a lot about you. But you have to know
how to understand and read the information for it to make any sense.
>> Well, I can't understand that, because that
just looks like a bunch of random letters,
to me.
>> Well, I guess so, in a sense, that's what
your genome is. A unique sequence of letters that has the
information to make up who you are. So, you're saying,
all of the cells in my body, they're just little letters?
>> Well, I guess so, in a sense. your genome's a
unique sequence of letters, much like this book in a unique
sequence of letters. But, in our genome, those letters are actually
symbols. They represent a very famous chemical substance that you can find
inside all your cells, and makes up the foundation of
your genome. DNA. We just learned in the last lesson
that DNA holds the secret to who we are. It's
a very special molecule that has many important functions not least
of which, is that it comprises the entirety of our
genome. Here's a concept map for lesson 2 that you can
also download from the instructor's notes and fill in the
blanks. Print it up or just keep it handy and see
if you can fill in those empty blanks as we go through the lesson. At
the end there will be an opportunity for you to fill in the missing words to
see a complete version. Remember if you prefer to have a complete lesson map as
you go through the lesson, you can always skip to the end, download it from the
[UNKNOWN]
notes and then you will have it. However, I
highly encourage you to use this incomplete version now.
Print it out, fill in the blanks, and then
at the end, you'll see how much you've learned.